I just burst into Nixon and I play a
character Jeju it was very very first
time I was playing with my cousin and my
sister's boyfriend told me hey dude why
it's to play this old game I was playing
well I think of something and he told me
at his new game called League of Legends
and it's like my doctor beta was out and
he was like who the game is [ __ ] cool
go play okay I'll go sign up on the page
you know I was like seem fine I'll tell
ya we can do HP nice I didn't go pacer
really good Jeju with just under 40 take
down let that thing get more serious I
ain't writing stuff on adenosine - I was
like 25 scale or something two or three
months before I signed with origin I
already wrote I else is cheating it's
cool like all I'm not doing bad school
or something like I was doing fine
anyone but I knew for sure that I was
not gonna finish school I was gonna go
pro there was like hesitation is like I
didn't wanna waste my time you know like
I didn't wanna go join a team and then
[ __ ] it up and come back a half year
later and say I didn't goes well I
wanted to always be a good team that
would make it far and you had two very
good options to make it very far so it
was pretty easy anything
because I short-lived the team as we
lost scoring games too and then we did
Spanish all right right after but ever
since that I just killed a bit and it's
working all day and waited for my make
moment like my opportunity and then it
came into his 14 at the end of the year
simple answer is yes he's got himself a
double kill as they turn their attention
on to camera shot beyond sports of
Shadows is there just to keep cabochons
alive the exhaust will hold them in
place
as meals will get himself a triple
origin will get there eight tower figure
and then there are the amazing art wars
and I think how I know it stories that
piggy just asked me to where we want
play with involving you can choose it's
your call and I think it was between me
and taps at that time in the end we just
played like some duo cues and stuff to
try out or whatever and then Becky added
me on geek and just talk to me a bit and
emotional games and I was a growl spent
my life in solitude that we're watching
we go LCS we go second place you go
finals five games and go gauntlet and we
should've lost broad cut but we didn't
and we go girls and you had it's like
burger on girls where we may have I
didn't expected or like hope and hope
for but didn't really think we would
really make it you know how I good
Gilliam we will have a fight at least so
but that year was really good year
that's a very very good first year for
origin and this is the first year of
professional play for Niels that ad
carry so he's got room to go pack a 1/4
like I ready for the that view what's
gonna be our year you know
I don't like talking so much about the
origin stuff because of like the
community backlash that happen and stuff
so it's a bit of a sensitive topic but
overall the main like cover of the
entire speech was to stay with Mickey
that was the most important thing so it
was only one place I could go with him
and I was here on top of being a good
like organization and good team it was
the best jump in try and do some more
damage but he really didn't have a lot
of a he's just kind of a tanky wreck
site who was now dead eight coming up
there from spent five for one and the
game itself G to 2 and 0 on the day over
Giants I think the most important thing
is that you should never expect too much
because then even I get let down on some
points but yeah I kind of knew that
we're gonna do well in split even if we
were not gonna do well anyways we're
gonna do well eventually like any
playoffs will be the best team or at
least a top team you know I always had
in mind that we were vesting no matter
what
I don't really play to make a name for
myself for like be the guy who has level
spotlights but I between you know but I
wouldn't mind having that kind of world
year I think last year at Worlds I was
really [ __ ] good so I would mind
having that kind of come once again but
the domingos will not to be in the
spotlight